America what happened like why why did
this whole debacle of a election occur
[Music]
what I know about Donald Trump is that
he has terrible hair angry orange
orangutan thing you know he's scary he's
actually really scary who's like racist
most people my age I think think that
this is a joke maybe Americans are too
used to reality television I lived in
Toronto in 2010 which is when Rob Ford
was elected mayor and this feels very
similar
I love reality TV but I just wouldn't
think that like anybody like from
Vanderpump rules for example with like
go run for office we were all in Toronto
we were all really sure that Rob Ford
could not and would not ever be elected
mayor do you think this is funny as a
Canadian I've like a little surprised by
it
people were encouraging Rob Ford to run
because they thought it would be funny
are you planning to move to another part
of the world running to Canada where are
you gonna live in Canada moving is not
going to solve your problems mainly
because you know you're right next door
like Trump will be right next door so
it's like not a guarantee of escape dear
Americans dear Americans dear American
make sure you vote because your vote
counts
it's time to be vigilant and to
participate do whatever it takes life to
the end if you need us
we're there for you good luck to all of
us
[Music]
he's not funny it's not funny
no laughing cuz it's scary
Oh